ん
i love 静岡いっぱい協議で久しぶりに茶畑に行ってきたんですけども今日朝僕
の特技がなんだかよくわからないんですけど多分皆さんにはない動力がサブ僕にはある
んですちょっとや何かと言いますとちょっと今そちらに対応がありますでもねこれ僕
いいなどうぞよくわかんないんですけども
ちょっと体呼びますねいきますよ
そうだね太陽ビルと必ずくしゃみが出ますこれなんだろうた言われる以上わかんないん
ですけどやっぱり太陽を見るとくしゃみが出るんですよ
入って外で今回の動画はなどちょっと嘘だと思ってる人いると思うよ本当にてるんです
よつも入ってやってるだけだっけんっ
いっ
どうだいいや別にカッコつけることじゃねえ俺マジな方で太陽1くしゃみが出ちまうん
だ
で今回はですねまずなんで出るんだろう太陽アレルギーとか所わかんないんですけど
ちょっとまずみんながてることもわからないんですけど僕はでは太陽を見るとくしゃみ
金なんか僕の友達たばけがでないって言ってたから僕だけのなんかとっきーかと思っ
てるわけですよ何かよくわからないんですけど今日はですねこの太陽
を見て臭みが出る特に言いますねターン連続くしゃみができるか実験してみようと思う
よ
太陽も力を借りて今日は僕のちょっとくしゃみの限界に行って待ってみようと思います
では行こう
ベトルールとしては本業と動画臭みとかに景色を楽しんでくれこの広大な茶畑最高じゃ
ないですか
杉はすぎます4位
実はそれちゃ
me
ああああああああ
通称リーナ連続していた海のかな連続性はないのかもしれない
ん
mar
長所リーナ貯蔵性が悪いので99
なんでだろうなぁいつもだと3つでるんですけど絵本脱いでるのは分かってますので
ますからね太陽の防水工なのかもしれない
宇佐美出ると待ちます頭そのうち出ると思うんだよ
やべーな
臭みが全然何が原因だったわからないようもそんなに弱くないと思うんですよ
rosso ホンギだしますもっと自分に素直しだろうこれはでる俺はでる俺は
くしゃみ出せる
dj 寺と言えるぞ戻ってきた半額が戻ってきた
太陽が強くなってきた
バッハよシュッシュッたと帰宅は来たぞみんな
皆きたバイオエネルギーきた
これさー
俺周りからみたらマジでヤバイ人だぜ対応を見てこんな顔してずっとカメラ回してんだ
よねもうちょっと頑張ってきました
まんだけどぞ
dj tasaka 春闘痛くなってきたあっはーんぜっ
bar はーい実施はパパっ子様の箱
へんしーん
研究室修了廃墟機でお分かりいただけましたでしょうかこれでみんな
的なかわかんないんだけどきっと太陽の力をエネルギーに変えてるよどーぞっ
バーって何を出せますよという僕の特技自慢でした
鯖の毛っていいよねじゃあ
今
ん
今入っ
プープーん